في ال عش من اكتوبر الجاري تعرضت كنيسه
الروم الارثوذكس برفيريوس بحي الزيتون في
غزه لقصف اسرائيلي اودى بحياه 20 شخصا
بينهم 18
[موسيقى]
مسيحيا المتحدث باسم جيش الاحتلال زعم ان
قصف ثالث اقدم كنيسه في العالم جرى عن
طريق الخطا وقال ان القوات كانت تستهدف
مبنى تابعا لحماس مجا للكنيسه التي تعود
لمطلع القرن الخامس الميلادي وحده التحقق
من المصادر المفتوحه بالجزيره سند حللت
مقاطع الفيديو المتاحه للوقوف على حقيقه
الروايه الاسرائيليه جيش الاحتلال نشر
مقطعا لعمليه القصف تم تعديل الفيديو لوضع
دائره حمراء على مبنى حماس المزعوم لكن
علامه التصويب كانت تشير نحو مبنى تابع
للكنيسه التي اشار اليها بدائره بيضاء
واظهر الفيديو ان الصاروخ توجه بشكل مباشر
لذلك المبنى وبعوده لخرائط جوجل عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه امكن تحديد تلك المباني
وتبين ان المبنى المستهدف هو ملحق للكنيسه
تقام فيه بعض فعالياتها ويعتقد انه كان
يؤوي نازحين فلسطينيين بمطابخ عدد من
العلامات المميزه ومقارنتها بالمقاطع
المصوره من الارض امكن تمييز الدمار في
المنطقه دمر جزء كبير من المبنى التابع
للكنيسه حيث كانت تشير علامه التصويب
بينما تعرض جزء منه لتدمير جزئي مع اتجاه
دخول الصاروخ الاسرائيلي بينما ظل المبنى
المستهدف المزعوم سليما تماما ولم
يمسسه التحقق الجيش الاسرائيلي تعمد قصف
كنيسه الروم الارثوذكس بغزه وتوجه الصاروخ
بدقه حيث وضعت علامه التصويب تمام
كما يفترض ان تفعل اسلحه جيش الاحتلال
عاليه الدقه والتطور التي تحرص الولايات
المتحده على تزويده
[موسيقى]
بها